hi I'm Matt Welch here with Nick
Gillespie from reason we're here on ask
a libertarian day in honor of the
paperback publication of our book the
Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America our next question
comes via Facebook from Dave Anthony am
rozina
on your people Nick is it possible for a
libertarian to support things like a
safety net vouchers for the especially
needy and Environmental Protection yeah
I I don't think that there's a
fundamental conflict libertarians are
not anarchists they believe in a minimal
government and a limited government in
the August September issue of Reason
magazine I co-authored a cover story
about getting rid of old age
entitlements and replacing them with a
safety net for the elderly or rather for
any any media Americans so I don't think
it's problem there's certain types of
environmental issues such as air
pollution that are best served through
collective action that leaves a lot of
room open for what are the best least
intrusive and most effective both in a
moral way as well as a you know a kind
of environmental way what are the best
solutions but there's not a conflict
I would I would amend that saying some
libertarians are certainly anarchists
and many people think theoretically in a
world would be treated better if there
were no safety nets Nick and I and
especially in the book we talk a lot
about kind of engaging with the world
and the framework that it exists right
now and how do we lead towards that so
if you like a safety net or if you think
that there should be a safety net you
have to be an opponent of entitlements
because entitlements are completely
bankrupting the country it's more than a
third of federal spending now it's gonna
be half the federal spending by 2030 so
if you like any of that stuff you're
gonna have to pick things to get rid of
and entitlements just by graduating to
age 65 you shouldn't get a lot of free
stuff and that is actually jeopardizing
the safety net much more than any crazy
libertarian ever could
you